c'est la nouvelle qui affole la planète
people si vous aimez la musique latina
le ballon rond et l'amour vous risquez
d'être très très déçu chaque état a payé
à l'afrique est en train et c'est
bernard et palace
et oui ça vient de tomber le footballeur
espagnol gerard piqué n'aime pas que
courir en chaussettes dans le sable mais
aussi voir d'autres nana en douce sauf
que shakira l'a bien grillées et du coup
lui a dit ciao qu'elle a piqué shakira
débat sous sol témoignent stanton et on
peut se demander quelle mouche l'a piqué
gérard avec une femme aussi convoité qui
lui fait même des chansons rien pour lui
[Musique]
attention pensez que les danses sexy de
shakira pourrait lui manquer il est
apparemment déjà passé à autre chose de
goudron
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors on and on a chaque iep être casse
tête
ça va nous coûter un peu cher parce que
les enfants est ensemble et d'éditer ça
peut coûter très très cher ares et ils
sont pas mariés se démonter ça coûte
cher très cher leur infidélité attention
attention variés si vous n'êtes pas
mariée et mon petit gars est ce qu'elles
ont des enfants à la mère elle est plus
riche que lui donc voici les soldats
impliqués à prendre un coût variant bien
appliquées par excès des vaccinés quatre
faux
puisqu'il est immensément riche parce
qu'un seul salaire de footballeur il a
aussi une société qui s'appelle cosmos
qui gère des tas d'événements sportifs
donc ça va lui coûter très cher elle est
partie à ibiza avec les deux enfants et
on dit que ça fait plusieurs mois en
fait mme qui sont plus vraiment ensemble
et lui il sort toutes les nuits ce
qu'elle n'a pas supporters aiment les
jeunes de barcelone était peut-être
boulanger
utilisons des mélodies tout le résultat
sportif mais il passe sa vie à sortir à
la passe et porté sa fiche à québec
alors juste en termes de pensions
alimentaires il ya des records il ya 3
millions d'euros versés par mail de ce
que dira sa précédente femme 3 millions
d'euros par mois par mois savard mois et
s'étaient connus dans deux minutes en
2000 2010 et s'était amené un million
quatre récemment en 2013 oui je peux
prendre cher
c'est à l'envi une ferme à la plupart ma
belle fille tu es petit tu vois toi mais
voilà ça peut arriver partout même dans
les coupes et de stas et c'est un couple
et ça arrive à s'enfuir sans bouger
la confiance en lui il ça peut arriver
de son côté comme du mien ya pas deux
à
on a bien
alex à notre sujet
j'avais des temps morts on se réunit à
la raison est là je comprends ce qu'a
dit j'ai confiance mais on on pense on
pense forcément que ça arrive que chez
la personne a médiatisé du couple où la
personne plus jeune ou la personne ah
mais non ça peut arriver partout moi là
et voilà sa place et orientale toni oui
bon ça paraît compliqué etc mais sait
surprendre parce que sinon c'est la mort
ses moufles je sais surprendre cyril
coomans doivent être âgés ou surprendre
de voir diderot bnm
[Rires]
on reste surpris à mykonos
vous allez adorer un accord très bien
dire ça dort et non mais elle coûte je
passerai une tête